[Music]
please passed on all we now the thousand
generations live in you now but this is
your fight
[Music]
[Applause]
we'll always be with you
[Music]
no one's ever really gone
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey everybody is Charlie we got a brand
new Star Wars Episode nine trailer to
break down so here we go if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos I will be doing
videos for the Star Wars Mandalorian TV
series when it gets here later this year
too we finally found out what the title
is the rise of Skywalker I wonder if
there meaning the Ascension of Skywalker
because Luke Skywalker forced ghost
voice over during the trailer there's
all these callbacks to the original
trilogy what looks like the second Death
Star it's hard to tell which one it is
because of the Emperor's voice over he
died on the second Death Star and the
fact that the Emperor's voice over is in
the trailer with that evil laughter no
one has ever really gone like Luke says
it sounds like something that they do
during the movie will require them to go
seek out something that used to belong
to Emperor Palpatine but during the
actual episode nine panel when JJ Abrams
was sort of talking about some details
he didn't give away too many things he
talked about the greatest evils at all
the characters the current characters
will face any sort of reference kylo Ren
in the same breath so just to make a
Marvel joke he made it sound like kylo
Ren in the first order are not the end
game threat there's some bigger evil and
obviously because of the evil Palpatine
laugh it makes it sound like Palpatine
has something to do with this greater
threat but also I love Ian McDiarmid
came out on stage and said roll the clip
again after they played the trailer in
full Palpatine voice they didn't say
what the names of these other planets
that they go to the desert planet that
looks very much like Tatooine obviously
you spent a lot of time back on Tatooine
during Return of the Jedi
it sounds like JJ Abrams referenced a
lot of Return of the Jedi things during
episode 9 the same way that he did with
episode 7 referencing a lot of
anewhopeee moments so make all the Death
Star jokes that you want oh great they
put another Death Star in here this just
looks like wreckage from the second
Death Star explosion the teaser trailer
opens with Rey breathing deeply
centering herself getting ready to be
run down by what seems like a more
advanced version or redesigned version
of kylo ren's tie silencer she ignites
Anakin Skywalker's lightsaber which she
has since repaired they didn't reveal
how much time has gone by but they say
enough time for her to have read most of
what's in those Jedi journals that she
took with her but not completely
everything they did unofficially confirm
in a
about way that she would be manifesting
new force abilities that we haven't seen
before as the Thai silencer approaches
quickly she does a backflip over it but
it looks like she's getting ready to
slice the top open with the lightsaber
because they cut the footage before you
see what happens next then there's a
shot of a brand new shuttle approaching
another one of the brand-new planets in
a city in a mountain rage amongst clouds
as if it were a city in the clouds
because Lando is in the movie so it
sounds like they're referencing a lot of
best Ben's stuff from Empire Strikes
Back they haven't said exactly what he's
doing during the film but at the end of
last Jedi Leia was talking about help
that she was going to call on it sounds
like Lando is the person that gives the
resistance a lot of help that they need
because they're basically decimated at
the end of last Jedi there's a new scene
of kylo Ren with the first order of
troops assaulting a planet taking down
this road figure with his lightsaber
this guy is completely red they
destroyed the area they did destroy the
super laser from the Starkiller base so
I don't know why the sky is red here if
it's just this planet or if they done
something else with some other huge
weapon that they have if we're
referencing a lot of return to the Jedi
moments there was a second death star
during Return of the Jedi maybe there's
some other second super weapon of some
sort in this then there's a new scene of
kylo Ren repairing his old helmet that
he smashed during episode eight there
are red glowing lines all over it now if
they keep that reddish glow it actually
would make the helmet look a little bit
cooler but these might just be lines
from him soldering it together there's a
new shot of Poe and Finn on that same
desert planet we have no idea when some
of these things are happening during the
movie it's all cut up there's very
little that we actually know about the
plot of the film we know about as much
of this film as we do of Avengers
endgame although Star Wars is not known
for working a lot of extra fake footage
into their trailers so I think this
trailer is less fake than all the
Avengers endgame trailers you get a
brand new shot of bb-8 in that new droid
do inside that resistance base there's a
shot of Chewie and Lando flying the
Millennium Falcon through hyperspace
it's a nice callback to Lando flying the
Falcon during Return of the Jedi not a
scratch honor I promise there's a brain
who shot a Poe Finn and c-3po on that
same desert planet in a speeder chase
through what seems like a moisture farm
flying from the first order I don't
expect this to be Tatooine but like they
spend a lot of time on Tatooine during
Return of the Jedi then being on this
desert planet is just a reference to
that so if they are like doing really
big callbacks this could be jakku or it
could be a completely different
but I'm not expecting them to go right
back to jakku cool shot up a couple of
first order stormtroopers flying through
the dust with jetpacks this is a
brand-new shot of a resistance a wing
flying across the bow of first order
Star Destroyer this actually seems like
it's Leia's hands holding one of the
rebellion medallions that she gave to
Luke han Solo and Chewbacca at the end
of a new hope so huge callback to that
if this really is the last film in the
Skywalker saga they're probably not just
referencing Return of the Jedi moments
they'll probably be callbacks to all the
films but this is an old scene of Leia
made to look new with Rey hugging each
other and raised new wider looking
outfit this designed a lot like the
Alpha she was wearing during episode 7
it's sort of a more polished version of
her episode 7 outfit made to look like
Jedi robes but the way they explained
all the Leia footage during episode 9 is
that it's all taken from unused or
deleted scenes from episode 7 in episode
8 that they shot with Carrie Fisher you
get all the Luke Skywalker force ghost
voice over saying we've passed on all we
know a thousand generations live in you
now clearly he's speaking to Rey during
this but this is your fight effectively
saying that they're passing the torch
now because Carrie Fisher has passed
away so the Leia character will probably
pass away during episode 9 Luke
Skywalker's passed away han Solo has
passed away so it's officially on them
now you get more force ghost Luke
Skywalker voice over talking to Ray wall
if she's hugging Leia saying we'll
always be with you sort of paying honor
to Carrie Fisher's passing in real life
but also Luke Skywalker telling ray that
we'll always be with you because force
ghost that's just the way things work in
the Star Wars universe you have all the
new mains on a different planet looking
at what looks like the wreckage like I
said of the second death star with the
Palpatine cackle in the background
here's the thing though if that is the
second Death Star's and that would be
endured that they're on just a very
different part of Endor than we've seen
before there were a couple images of the
film they released of them on a forest
planet that could be this same place
which would mean if this is the second
death star that they go back to Endor
which isn't so much a Return of the Jedi
reference as then literally going back
to Return of the Jedi
but it seems like whatever they're here
for it has something to do with
Palpatine and something during like the
big mission of the film this greater
evil that JJ Abrams is teasing so the
title of the rise of Skywalker probably
has something to do with
second death star with the Palpatine of
it all with the ascension of Luke
Skywalker to force ghost status but also
because this is the end of the Skywalker
saga they'll probably be a lot of
references to Anakin Skywalker the will
of the force and a lot of the broader
mythology that they've teased out during
the Clone Wars series if you didn't know
they actually bringing back Clone Wars
for that Disney Plus streaming service
but I don't think that those episodes
will air til next year sometime so it'll
be a while before we get new Clone Wars
but the real big question to me though
is is what kylo Ren is going to do
before he goes out in this film because
he's the last living member of the
Skywalker family and if the title is the
rise of Skywalker is the title also a
reference to the rise of kylo Ren in a
much bigger way like the way that Darth
Vader was redeemed at the end of Return
of the Jedi before he passed away is the
same thing going to happen to kylo Ren
if he either dies or if he continues on
living but he's been redeemed that's a
whole other question to whether or not
you think the kylo Ren walks away from
this or if he dies before the end of the
film but because it is the very last
film I would expect all kinds of
surprise cameos the Emperor Palpatine
one is probably the biggest surprise
that was such a funny moment after they
played the trailer like oh you thought
this was just a funny wink at the camera
that we were doing no I'm actually here
at Star Wars Celebration the Emperor
tells you to roll the clip again so
listen to this clip of JJ Abrams talk
about the quote unquote greater threat
and let me know if you think that he's
teasing some other bigger thing instead
of just kylo Ren in the first order in
addition to being the end of three
trilogies monied z-- to work as its own
movie and that's been part of the the
fun of it part of the challenge of it
but this movie it's about this new
generation and and what they've
inherited the the light and the dark and
asking the question as they face the
greatest evil are they prepared are they
ready the way he tries to talk around it
just makes it sound like kylo Ren is not
the ultimate evil of this film like
there'll be something else that has
something to do with Palpatine in them
at this second Death Star wreckage is a
really big news you may have heard is
that Star Wars movies after Episode nine
are gonna be on hiatus indefinitely
meaning it'll probably be at least three
to four years before we find out what
the next Star Wars film is gonna be but
they're still doing the trilogy that the
Game of Thrones producers are making we
don't know what that's going to be about
there's a lot of
about Knights of the Old Republic it
could be any kind of trilogy Ryan
Johnson is also still doing his trilogy
we know a little bit more about that so
for the next couple of years the only
new Star Wars content that we're getting
is gonna be the TV stuff that they're
doing on the Disney Plus streaming
service they said that the Star Wars
Mandalorian series is gonna be available
at the launch of the Disney Plus
streaming service November 12th they
didn't say exactly how they're gonna
release episodes if it'll be Netflix
style where they dump everything or if
they do one episode per week there's
gonna be a panel for the Mandalorian
series will they'll probably release the
teaser trailer on Sunday night because
Sunday is also the premiere of Game of
Thrones season eight that's basically
what my videos will be Sunday it'll be
the Star Wars trailer for the
Mandalorian Series in the morning and
then I'll do my Game of Thrones episode
one video that night while you wait for
everything click here for that brand new
Avengers endgame trailer and click here
to get ready for Game of Thrones Season
eight thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome see you guys
tonight